les blessures sont encore visibles ce
cheval a été retrouvé mutilé ce week end
avec deux profondes entailles
ils ont essayé de sectionner le tendon
avec une inscription certainement fait
avec un cutter ou imputent aux on peut
lire des lettres lci lci
voilà donc ils étaient enflés ils
étaient un peu traumatisés ils avaient
peur c'est gratuit ce la barbarie et la
cruauté s'est placée sous anti
inflammatoires
ce poulain de deux ans est désormais
hors de danger la propriétaire a décidé
de changer de près tous ces animaux et
de porter un gentil cheval depuis le
début du mois d'août les gendarmes
jurassiens ont dénombré cinq cas de
mutilation sur des chevaux à chaque fois
les actes ont lieu de nuit
l'angoissé donc de plus en plus palpable
dans le monde équin ses propriétaires
jurassien très inquiet n'ont d'ailleurs
pas souhaité que l'on filmé leurs
animaux en ce moment il ne donne
quasiment plus on restait éveillés dans
la voiture pour être à l'abri mais on
surveille on voit les efforts des
autorités et s'il ya le moindre chose
suspects auront on se déplace pour se
rendre compte de ce qui se passe on fait
de l'élevage c'est pas pour se faire
massacrer nos shows donc oui c'est un
stress permanent
le procureur de la république de
lons-le-saunier invite les éventuels
témoins se manifester et recommande aux
propriétaires d'examiner régulièrement
leurs chevaux une enquête a été confiée
à la section de recherches de besançon